[Música]
o código a hoje lhe o golo ea o
brasileiro era mesmo esse o uso ea pneu
front aí e aí eu com a no burro negro no
um bo ea yahoo com a globo e aí com a
noiva e eu com a no boca já o com a no
google ea yahoo com a no boca akon ano
ea e nêgo nua no bo e ou com a no gol e
é com a globo e com a no boca com a
globo e com amor com amor e com amor ea
o com a globo nem pleno ano e dano a no
google ea yahoo com a novo e com a no
boca com a nu e negro não anuiu a ueg e
com no gol ea o com a globo e é bom
senso a o ie é com a novo i e guerrón a
o tinha o plano e nem continuar no itaú
e e com a no gol ea ou com anuía akon
ano ou um ano um gol
o e e corre o gol negro no ano lei e
economia ou bom o vôo 11 anos
[Música]
a treinar
[Aplausos]
boa tarde gente botar todo mundo
fronteira o que a fronteira o que a
fronteira que a fronteira
eu também não sei o que acontece mas
parece que a fronteira se uma limita uma
linha imaginária para dividir 2
território assim o uma limite com uma
pessoa não pode ultrapassar a fronteira
da língua
fortunato agentes e alfredo os países
contracultural pra mim é o meu sonho não
tem que ter fronteira nesse mundo no
melhor sonho hoje está a dizer assim
está ficando uma realidade assim eu
africano da costa do marfim num país de
língua processo tocando no mesmo palco
uma cultura que minha com o chileno que
fala bem espanhol
parabéns pra você hoje o seu aniversário
foi manter muito obrigado para vez eu
sou de uma cultura de uma tradição onde
o tempo passado era so pra os homens
tocar mas eu o meu sonho é abrir pra as
mulher conseguir tocar hoje eu estou
aqui num barco tocando com uma
brasileira e uma brasileira do brasília
muito obrigado eu também tocando com uma
brasileira do dodô
nota-se isso né pergunta se isso a andré
sá ferreira aglutinar a mim o josé
leônidas então esse grupo se chama ação
com foco são como aqueles a buscar nas e
aí eu estou buscando essa cultura
naraísa sempre abrindo as fronteiras
musicais e culturais porque a gente pode
tocar um ritmo que é dar porque há uma
cultura africana aqui no brasil porque a
música não tem fronteiras na afinal
temos fronteira e aí essa experiência
aqui eo me deu assim vontade passa a
equipar compartilhar isso com vocês
assim um grupo de percussão africana
esse preço o integrante que africana na
cultura notem fronteira então muito
obrigado e espero que vocês estão
gostando
[Música]
ricardo imagem
eu vou fazer algumas fãs daqui eu
mostrei vamos te dar
por isso junto tá bom
la bande dessinée mundo sempre é é um
então vou fazer assim do gata tatá pt
eu a vi o que eu faço né tv
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a boa assim o amor
vamos pegar lançar o contrapiso breve
lançar em breve lançar um programa de
dança
vamos junto tá bom tá bom eu to a
a globo
[Música]
obrigado a arrancar
ae
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o rival a